put on my three by my powerful three by
three i actually did put
no country for all men oh wow what's
interesting is off camera
this is mine this is mine yeah yeah yes
this one off camera uh
jewelry's like oh yeah honestly i was so
close to putting some of these on mine i
know you were going to put that oh
okay okay because i was like i was like
maybe someone else is going to put it
man but that was so close to coming on
my way this is a powerful list i think
gentlemen i think
you know what the only one that
i probably have like a little bit of
qualms with
is uh tokyo no absolutely not this isn't
a masterpiece
if we're talking about overrated films
tokyo drift uh it is not overrated
listen the main actor
you know his entire fast and furious
franchise i've ever written he's
actually
i said he's he's an impeccable character
actor the main actor in tokyo drift you
know i don't know if you're being
serious he
he he he enveloped like he nothing is
mimicked living in japan
quite like tokyo dream you're right
you're right when i went to school and
some
and you know i love all one japanese
actors in this you know
you know when i was in school in japan
with my black friend from america um
we dreamed of going to japan one day and
we were like what is the closest we can
get to it
you know i think every
every single point of tokyo drift is a
masterclass in filmmaking frankly uh
from the very start you know in the
american high school scene it's very
very much like how it is to be in
america yeah and naturally i race my
cars and
uh i cause a lot of damage and don't get
arrested and get exiled
which i don't think is a punishment that
you see you know a lot of movies they
would just arrest him
yeah and i think it was really genius
well you know full speed drifting
through a parking lot which is just you
know if you've ever been to a parking
lot in any country it's just impossible
so there's not enough movies that use
exile as a as a good
way of conveying the story
name a movie with exile on it i'll wait
there we go
for good reason it's a med evil concept
that it hasn't been introduced in modern
films you know
exile exile he was exiled from arkansas
some i don't know where the [ __ ] he was
i don't know some hick town yeah and you
know his accident is just amazing i love
i love this guy's accent so
so much i love the accent i don't think
i've ever felt physical pain while
watching a movie before
until i watched it i'm gonna be honest i
have not seen a single fast and furious
film uh i've only seen
tokyo drift you know and i you know
because i didn't want to i didn't want
to be
annoyed because we'd already found the
best fast and furious film so why
watching
god i must say you are not missing out
on it no no tokyo
have you watched your drift i i
literally just said five seconds ago
literally five seconds i don't know is a
fast and furious film
no i don't count this as a foster future
it's a cinema experience it's a totally
different
it's somehow worse no it's it's if you
add up all the imdb scores of the fast
and furious films it's still not as high
as tokyo direct
like yeah because like 0.
there's not much zero plus zero is still
zero tokyo drift is a great film
uh that is close to my heart um in many
ways uh not only did it get me into uh
donkey kong uh because of the dk oh yeah
of course yeah
that compelled me to check out donkey
kong the beginning of monkey
this is actually this is the monkey
origin story
you know it's almost it's just there's
nothing quite
as uh groundbreaking as this film quite
frankly
so what's your favorite scene uh i like
the scene
where he breaks his ipod and then he
still manages to sell the ipod
broken and then he doesn't check to he
doesn't check to
to check the ipod before buying it i
believe this is what happens
and then he purchased the ipod then gets
annoyed that it was broken yeah but he
never once thought i should check this
ipod before buying it
uh classic and that's just a great i
thought that was a really intelligent
scene because
that's how they made conflict through a
broken ipod what i want to know is
um how are there so many fast and
furious films
uh well you this actually saved the fast
and furious franchise
it was actually no i don't know i think
a dead ass might have because it's like
this was the first when you hear of
someone saying fast and furious i think
of tokyo drift yeah they're right most
people i think think of tokyo drift and
i'm like why
like do the other fast and furious films
even have names how does it like
no it's like one two three four memes
aside
how does such a [ __ ] film become so
iconic like that's what i want to do
like just like it is it is terrible by
every single metric of the english word
but i love this film to death
it's like the room right it's like the
room of fast and furious
because it's just it's just got the
coolest name
i mean tokyo drift right it's a [ __ ]
cool last time
so legit i know we spoke about this
before but like it was kind of like a
gateway for me to japan like yeah
it goes actually it kind of legit got me
into japan in many ways i'm sorry it was
it was
better it's great because then i got to
learn actual [ __ ]
all right also it was the very first dvd
i ever owned
uh it was totally fair enough yeah and
it's in a glass cabinet as you can
imagine i
think that i think i think the vacuum
sealed yeah
yeah mint condition has been graded
obviously